- Most likely to be caught
napping in-between scenes is me.
I'm all about that napping life.
(dramatic music jingle)
- Felicity has that strength, definitely.
- Felicity, a lot of people don't know
she kind of grew up doing
horse riding, woodwork, and
archery kind of survival school stuff,
so she's kind of a military bad ass.
- Felicity.
Mainly because she's good with sticks.
And she'll smack you down.
If you upset her.
That and she's a leader.
- I think Riz.
- [Riz] The biggest Star
Wars nerd or fan is,
actually not somebody in
the cast, it's the director.
It's Gareth Edwards,
he's a complete fanboy.
- Gareth Edwards.
- Gareth.
He knew everything.
- There was a competition
between Alan Tadyk
and Gareth Edwards.
- Some would probably say me,
but I'm gonna say Ben Mendelsohn.
- I mean, it has to be Donnie Yen.
- Me.
- I think Mendelsohn.
- I did a few.
I have to admit, now that I can,
and they cannot cut me out of the film.
I did take a lot.
- Riz, let's just say Riz even
though it's probably not Riz.
- Well on set actually
we weren't aloud phones.
So you couldn't take selfies, actually.
What you'd have to do
is when the costume or
continuity people were taking
photos of you as a reference
of your costume you'd have to
just be like take shots of me.
Send it to me later.
- Probably be Diego.
With you know tequila or
mezcal involved at some point.
- I would say Diego Luna
would initiate the hangout.
It would never take place,
but he'd initiate it.
- I'm qualified to take that one.
Yes.
- Me.
Not true.
It's true.
- I had the difficult task
of being next to Alan Tudyk
that is so much fun,
and he just can't stop.
So he makes it very difficult
for those around him.
- Well any scene with Diego,
Alan and I it was very hard
to keep a straight face.
And there would be a lot of
trying to hold onto your cheeks
as your laughing too much.
- Jiang Wen is most likely to nail a scene
on the first take.
- Probably Mads.
It's just he's such a good actor
but I never worked with him
but oh, that guys got skills.
- That would be Diego.
- I have to say Darth Vader.
I don't want him to look at this interview
and not be mentioned.
I might start going
(choking noise) oh God!
So, Darth Vader.
- Probably Forest Whitaker.
Partly because he's Forest
Whitaker, and he comes in
with a ridiculous level of preparation.
But also because he's Forest Whitaker.
So, um, good luck to the
person that goes to tell him
he has to do it again.
- Alan.
- Alan Tudyk.
And he gets away with it, for some reason.
- Alan Tudyk, again, yeah.
I should really manage Alan Tudyk,
and launch him as a stand-up comedian.
- Alan Tudyk.
Insane.
- I do a pretty good Diego Luna.
Alan, I have to tell you the
whole crew is very sad now.
- One day he was, yeah
he was doing my voice,
and it was quite scary.
He does it right.
(swoosh and screech noise)